auf der anderen seite gibt es jetzt
diese erfolge des ukrainischen militärs
auch der ukrainischen zivilbevölkerung
muss man sagen die machten nur wladimir
putin offensichtlich immer wütender
glauben sie dass sich im weiteren
verlauf jetzt einfach immer noch mehr
tote und noch mehr leid geben wird ja
also einerseits gibt es so eine stimmung
in der ukraine manche wundern sich warum
wir immer noch so sicher sind dass die
ukraine gewinnt und es gibt auch eine
stimmung dass das bald vorbei wird
wahrscheinlich ist es auch eine
schutzreaktion
ich versuche pessimistisch zu bleiben
oder realistisch und wenn ich die
nachrichten lese die manchmal wirklich
ganz schrecklich sind dann denke ich wir
stehen aber am anfang wir werden noch
schlimmere sachen erfahren und das ist
etwas worauf ich mich auch innerlich
vorbereitet und das muss man auch glaube
ich hier in europa bei all diesen
diskussionen auch im auge behalten das
ist nicht das ende und obwohl die
ukraine einen enormen widerstand leisten
und alle das bewundern ist das eine sehr
schwierige situation und kann es kann
wirklich noch schlimmer sein sie haben
vor dem krieg bei uns in der sendung
unserer anfang februar gesagt dass die
ukraine sich überhaupt gar nicht fragen
was putins ziel ist und uns gefragt
worauf wir eigentlich noch warten wie
kommt ihnen diese diskussionen die wir
heute in deutschland führen vor
ich glaube man muss ein bisschen
schneller sein ich glaube viele sachen
die wir damals diskutiert haben vor
allem waffenlieferungen ist ja jetzt
klar jetzt gibt es andere fragen auf dem
tisch man muss einfach schneller sein
ich habe das gefühl
diese entscheidungen die heute unmöglich
aussehen in zwei wochen ganz einfach
getroffen werden können aber haben wir
diese zwei wochen oder haben wir in
dieser zeit und unter wer meine ich
nicht nur ukrainisch meinen natürlich
auch europa genau darüber werden wir
diskutieren carlo masala ist bei uns
militärexperte von der bundeswehr
universität münchen deshalb werden wir
werden wir sehen dass wladimir putin
weil unter druck immer brutaler wird
mutter nein ich glaube nicht das ist der
punkt ist nicht dass er unter druck ist
und deshalb brutaler wird das was wir
erlebt haben die berichte über die
systematischen vergewaltigungen von
frauen über die exekution von zivilisten
das ist ja ein teil russische militär
strategie also das ist kommt nicht
überraschend wenn man sich anschaut wie
russland sich in anderen regionen
verhalten hat
das ist zwar keine eins zu eins kopie
aber das ist jetzt nicht glaub ich
darauf zurückzuführen dass die
enttäuschung groß ist dass man zum
beispiel kiew nicht einnehmen konnte
sondern russland muss sich zurückziehen
ja und begeht im zuge dieses rückzugs
genau diese vernichtung die wir jetzt
sehen und wo ich das teil wir werden
noch viel mehr sehen ich städten wie
mario pohl und sowas kommt ja keine
unabhängige presse rein oder in die ost
ukraine das ist leider gottes ein teil
der russische militärstratege das ist
kein zufall dass es systematik und da
geht es darum den widerstand der
ukrainischen zivilbevölkerung zu brechen
es geht darum die ukrainische
zivilbevölkerung zu demütigen und damit
sozusagen auf der einen seite haben sie
eine armee die kämpft auf der anderen
seite haben sie eine bevölkerung die den
kampf dieser armee massiv unterstützt
mit dem was es kann und eine der
zentralen elemente ist es die
bevölkerung sozusagen von ihrer armee zu
distanzieren weil die bevölkerung
kriegsmüde ist was dann wiederum
auswirkungen auf seelands die politische
führung und die militärische führung hat
und dazu zählen vergewaltigungen dazu
zählen massaker an gräueltaten wie wir
sie jetzt erleben friedrich merz ist bei
uns fraktionsvorsitzender der
cdu/csu-fraktion parteivorsitzende der
cdu
viele sagen herr merz dass es dass diese
kriegsgräuel so
grauenhaft sind und so erschütternd sind
weil sie mitten in europa geschehen
mal unabhängig davon dass offensichtlich
uns eben auch viel gleichgültigkeit
gewinnen geben war um andere kriege zu
ignorieren hätten mir etwas viel früher
sehen und viel früher ahnen können ja
wir haben damals aber hatte es ja gerade
gesagt diese bilder ja nicht zum ersten
mal gesehen sie waren beim letzten mal
nur weiter weg sie waren in aleppo in
syrien in tschetschenien das ist eben in
der tat ein muster und jetzt ist es sehr
nah bei uns das mitten in europa und
jetzt reagieren werden umstellen
plötzlich uns selbst die frage was haben
wir da eigentlich weggeschaut und was
war der grund dafür wir haben wirklich
geglaubt das könnte hier nicht
stattfinden jetzt findet es hier statt
und ist öffnet uns die augen sie haben
in einem namensartikel geschrieben dass
putin sein wahres gesicht uns in syrien
schon gezeigt hat und
die nächste frage ist natürlich liegt
auf der hand hat er uns also richtig
eingeschätzt in unserem tschetschenien
interessiert uns noch nicht syrien
interessiert uns noch nicht und wir
reagieren genau wie sie sagen erst jetzt
wo es vor der eigenen haustür er hat uns
wahrscheinlich bis zu beginn dieses
krieges richtig eingeschätzt aber danach
nicht mehr ich vermute dass er jetzt
realisiert dass wir uns wirklich wehren
und das ist auch eine gute sache so
schrecklich und so tragisch dieser krieg
ist aber jetzt ist es wirklich gut und
er merkt dass und er muss seine
strategie ständig ändern was nicht heißt
dass es dadurch besser wird aber man
muss ja mal mit großem respekt sagen was
dieses volk der ukraine leistet was die
menschen dort leisten was sie auch
bereit sind zu erdulden und zu ertragen
ist wirklich ändert ja es ist auch
herzzerreißend was da geschieht und
deswegen wollen wir ja nun auch endlich
und wirklich helfen darüber reden wir
jetzt mit christian dem
fraktionsvorsitzenden der fdp was muss
hätte butscher was muss das schicksal
der zivilbevölkerung nicht nur dieser
stadt sondern weil ich viele ukrainische
städte an unserer politik ändern herr
merz hat gesagt wir waren naiv
wahrscheinlich zehn zwanzig jahre waren
wir gegenüber russland komplett naiv ich
meine wir haben vor ein paar monaten in
deutschland noch ernsthaft über note 2
gesprochen das ist ja im nachhinein fast
absurd wenn wir jetzt darüber nachdenken
und ich teile das was sie gesagt haben
roger wird mutmaßlich nicht der einzige
grüne ort sein in der ukraine und von
daher zeitenwende ist ja das allgemeine
sprichwort jetzt in deutschland das ist
es ich will es mal so zu sagen fassen
freuen ich glaube der westen deutschland
hat drei optionen das erste wäre und das
ist keine ein direkter eintritt in den
krieg das ist keine option das zweite
ist wir müssen die wirtschaftlichen
beziehungen zu russland abbrechen bei
der kohle beispielsweise wir kommen da
sicherlich noch drauf bei der kohle
haben wir seit beginn dieses krieges ist
in deutschland zumindest geschafft zu 50
prozent die abhängigkeit also die
abhängigkeit gegenüber russischen quote
zu halbieren und das dritte sind
waffenlieferungen
die deutsche bundesregierung hat ja
gerade vor ein paar tagen panzer aus
deutschen bestand ursprünglich die jetzt
in tschechien sind freigegeben
bewaffnete panzer damit sie dort
hinkommen also wir haben jetzt
handlungsoptionen die wir nutzen müssen
und darüber einer meinung auch schwere
waffen ist putin in ihren augen ein
kriegsverbrecher würden sie das sagen
der bundeskanzler wehrt sich immer noch
dieses wort in den mund zu nehmen ich
habe das wort nach butter in den mund
genommen weil das sind kriegsverbrechen
die müssen angeklagt werden in den haag
dazu werden wir später noch kommen das
ist auch dann die aufgabe der
zivilisierten welt das aufzuarbeiten
putin hatte ja nie die hätten die sorge
haben müssen dass die ukraine irgendwie
aggressiv ist sondern putins angst ist
dass die liberale demokratie zu nah an
seine grenzen gerutscht ist und vor dem
hintergrund verteidigen die menschen der
ukraine die liberale demokratie des
westens derzeit und ja also das sind
kriegsverbrechen wie hier sind mit
stefan wolf verbunden und zwar in
stuttgart er ist vorstandsvorsitzender
von elringklinger und präsident von
gesamtmetall also ein klassischer
unternehmer und manager
herr wolf dieses embargo über das die
ganze zeit in deutschland heißt
diskutiert wird
ist jetzt ein embargo gegen russische
kohle es ist noch keins gegen gas und
gegen öl
würden sie auch sagen als mensch als
unternehmer als verantwortlicher
unternehmer dass man dass es uns weniger
schuldig machen würde wenn es uns
gelänge ein komplettes energie in bargum
mit russland hin zu bekommen oder gegen
zunächst mal die bilder die wir sehen
sind grauenhaft und wir als arbeitgeber
sind entsetzt was da passiert und
vorteilen das natürlich zutiefst ich
glaube aber dass die sachverhalte nicht
vergleichbar sind wir haben als
arbeitgeberin als unternehmer
verantwortung für unglaublich viele
menschen in deutschland dass die einen
arbeitsplatz haben dass sie leben können
dass sie ihre gasrechnung ihre
stromrechnungen bezahlen können und
mit der kohle das kriegen wir hin aber
wenn sie das thema gas ansprechen die
abhängigkeit vom gas ist enorm in
deutschland von russischem gas das
schwankt die angaben zwischen 2 und 15
55 prozent und wenn wir morgen diese
gaslieferungen abstellen dann droht ein
totaler kollaps der deutschen industrie
der chemischen industrie wenn sie dort
prozesse unterbrechen die fahren sie
nicht schnell wieder hoch wenn sie die
glasindustrie nehmen wenn diese wannen
runtergefahren werden unter 40 grad dann
sind sie kaputt das sind enorme
investitionen die dann wieder getätigt
werden müssen die lieferkette in der
fahrzeug- und zulieferindustrie da kenne
ich mich nun besonders gut aus die wäre
total unterbrochen und das würde
zunächst mal dazu führen dass wir
millionen von menschen erstmal in
kurzarbeit null schicken dann aber auch
viele kleine mittlere unternehmen in der
metall elektro industrie sicherlich das
nicht überleben werden wir müssen immer
daran denken wir haben zwei schwierige
jahre hinter uns den unternehmen geht es
nicht gut und wir haben eigentlich
darauf gehofft dass es jetzt wieder nach
oben geht und wenn wir dann massenweise
menschen in die arbeitslosigkeit
schicken in deutschland dann haben wir
glaube ich nichts gekonnt in dieser
situation brauchen wir ein starkes
deutschland und eine starke wirtschaft
die in der lage ist auch
erwirtschaften arbeitsplätze zu erhalten
und auch geld zu erwirtschaften weil wir
haben immer noch eine enorme aufgabe vor
uns wir müssen uns autark machen von
russischem gas und von russischer
energie und da brauchen wir ja enorme
investitionen es braucht zeit und da
brauchen wir aber enorme investitionen
um dieses geld muss irgendwo
erwirtschaftet werden und ich glaube
wenn wir jetzt geld erwirtschaften dass
wir dann in windkraftanlagen stecken in
deutschland um uns autark zu machen von
russischer energie der und arbeitsplätze
für die menschen in unserem land
erhalten dass sie leben können dann
haben wir wirklich was gekonnt das war
jetzt schon der ganze große strauß ich
sag mal das erste argument von norbert
röttgen herr merz wäre zu sagen der viel
größere schaden für die deutsche
wirtschaft entsteht ein xxl schaden wenn
putin gewinnen sollte weil dann unsere
chancen in europa mal noch ganz anders
aussehen als sie sein könnten wenn es
irgendwann einen frieden gibt was ist
ihre position
diskutieren über dieses thema fast jede
woche und es gibt bei uns in der cdu
aber auch in der bundestagsfraktion
viele die sagen müssten wir nicht jetzt
wirklich zu den rigorosen mitteln
greifen die wir zur verfügung haben
arbeiten sie denn mehr verhindern wir ja
das gibt aber auch andere und meine
antwort ist wenn wir wüssten dass am tag
danach oder sagen wir zwei wochen danach
dieser krieg beendet wäre würden das tun
aber wir wissen es nicht und wir haben
hier abzuwägen und zwar nicht die eine
moral gegen die andere oder die moral
gegen die wirtschaft sondern wir haben
doch abzuwägen was das auch für folgen
hätte und herr wolf hat gerade mal auch
angedeutet wir müssen damit rechnen dass
es passiert dass putin von sich aus die
gaslieferung stoppt wir müssen ernsthaft
damit rechnen aber müssen wir das
wirklich selbst machen um jetzt noch
größeren schaden entstehen zu lassen
nochmal ich kann gut verstehen wenn man
anderer meinung ist aber die mehrheit
bei uns sagt wir sollten es nicht tun
wir sind jetzt runter übrigens jawoll
von
50 auf 40 prozent also nicht neid die
abhängigkeit singt jede woche wir tun
alles um die unabhängigkeit zu erreichen
aber
wir müssen jetzt nicht noch zum
härtesten mittel gegen uns auch selbst
greifen mit ungewissem ausgang in diesem
krieg und das ist das dilemma in dem bei
uns jeden tag befinden wir ringen da
wirklich und glauben sie mir ferner das
ist keine entscheidung die 10 oder 100
zu null ausfällt sondern das ist eine
entscheidung die jeden tag neu abgewogen
wird und wir kommen zu diesem ergebnis
europäische parlament heute anders die
evb fraktion im europäischen parlament
vater hat genau aber das ist eine
position ich finde wir haben für beide
positionen gute gründe ich komme zu
einem anderen ergebnis mit der mehrheit
meiner kolleginnen und kollegen wissend
was auch dass keine position ist mit der
wir uns jetzt innerlich auch wirklich
wohl fühlen es ist ein tägliches ringen
um die richtigen antworten ich bevor ich
ein dur frage frage an herrn masala
wladimir putin hatte atomwaffen und wir
sind wahnsinnig abhängig von russischem
gas ändert sich an diesen beiden
prämissen etwas je länger und je
grausamer dieser krieg wird
an den prämissen ändert sich überhaupt
nichts
der punkt ist natürlich sind diese
atomwaffen da und natürlich sozusagen
gibt es situationen diesen konflikt die
dazu führen könnten dass die atomare
bedrohung wieder im raum steht ja also
dann dem müssen wir uns sozusagen dann
dem müssen wir uns vergegenwärtigen dass
müssen im hinterkopf haben wir sind
abhängig vom gas aber wenn ich mir
erlauben darf ich bin kein ökonomen aber
was mich stört an der deutschen
diskussion ist sie wird sehr binär
geführt also entweder wir stoppen morgen
oder wir lassen es laufen bis wir
irgendwann mal unabhängig sind es gibt
andere länder wie frankreich oder
italien da werden zwischen schritte
diskutiert und die fehlen mir hier in
der deutschen diskussion also
es ist wohl so dass man den öl ausstieg
wohl verkraften konnte auch so kohle
sowieso aber kohle sozusagen ist ist der
eu beschluss ist ein bisschen lächerlich
wenn ich das sagen darf
es ist die möglichkeit da bin ich robert
habeck richtig verstanden habe und herr
merz hat das ja auch gesagt wir werden
immer weniger abhängiger kann man
darüber nachdenken die fördermengen zu
reduzieren zu einem solchen bereich dass
diese grund industrie noch weiterlaufen
kann aber wir sozusagen nicht alles
abnehmen müssen was wir jetzt abnehmen
kann man russisches gas besteuern und
damit sozusagen weniger geld in diesem
startspiel
weil natürlich finanziert das gas nicht
den krieg aber es finden ziert den start
der den krieg führt und diese ganzen
zwischenschritte die fehlen mir in der
deutschen diskussion wir machen das sehr
bitter entweder komplett oder halt
überhaupt nicht und da finde ich
sozusagen sollte man auch mal ins
europäische ausland gucken wir mal
gucken so was dort die kollegen und
kolleginnen also ihre diskutieren und
mal schauen in wie weit man das in
deutschland übernehmen kann und wellness
und werden wir uns dazu entschließen
kann also sozusagen diesen stopp nicht
durchzuführen was man ja akzeptieren
muss wenn die politik zu dieser
entscheidung kommt dann müssen wir aber
verdammt noch mal bei den
waffenlieferungen aber wirklich aufs gas
steigt also wir können nicht auf der
einen seite der bremser sein und auf der
anderen seite sehr zögerlich seien
waffenlieferungen angeht wir sind die
fünftgrößte volkswirtschaft profitieren
enorm von sicherheit und stabilität auf
diesem europäischen kontinent wir haben
einen bundeskanzler und auch ein
oppositionsführer die sagen wie
bedeutend dieser konflikt ist da können
wir nicht so eine in between haltung des
vision sozusagen die eine seite schließt
mehr komplett aus weil sie uns ruinieren
würde und auf der anderen seite drücken
wir so ein bisschen auf die bremse weil
wir auch nicht zu sehr provozieren
wollen das geht aus der
oppositionsführer nicht warum das us
unternehmen wies das zurück ehrlich
gesagt dann lassen sie uns über dieses
embargo reden und vielleicht später noch
einmal dazu kommen was eigentlich ziele
sind auch ziele des westens in bezug auf
putin weil ich merke dass wir in dieser
diskussion jetzt schon sehr drin sind
genau wir diskutieren in deutschland
nicht nur hier und heute abend über
unsere schärfste waffe und das ist das
wir brauchen eine isolierung von
russland weil jeder cent der auch für
gas bezahlt wurden wird für waffen
verwendet die heute fehlen der druck
wächst
berlin hält dagegen es ist ein spiel auf
zeit wir verfolgen ja eine strategie uns
unabhängig von russischen gas von kohle
und öl zu machen nur eben nicht sofort
wir können nicht jahrelang warten bis
lieferungen aus katar hier ankommen ein
sofortiges energie embargo nicht
verkraftbar sagt die wirtschaft
zusammenbruch der lieferketten
kurzarbeit rezession die mengen werden
kurzfristig nicht ersetzt die auswirkung
eines kurzfristigen embargos auf uns
sind deutlich größer als
höchstwahrscheinlich der effekt in
russland werden wir gar kein erdgas mehr
bekommen heißt es hier leben still in
brüssel hat man sich formal auf ein cola
embargo geeinigt ein bruchteil der
überweisungen an den kreml
bei öl und gas geht das spiel auf zeit
weiter das letztlich dann eine
politische entscheidung ob man bereit
ist diese wirtschaftlichen kosten die
das auch für uns hätte zutragen
aber eher machbar wäre es
und das ist ein wissenschaftler der sagt
hatte dass
diese volkswirtschaft aushält ist
deutschland mittlerweile use also
wirklich isoliert auch innerhalb der
europäischen union weil die italiener
sind jetzt dafür das ist ein auch gas
embargo gibt wir haben österreich noch
an unserer seite unglaublich und
slowenien
sind wir dabei auch diese mehrheit in
der eu sogar gegen uns sagt so jetzt
müssen ein bisschen differenzieren also
diese zwischenschritte marcel
angesprochen hat die tun wir ja bei cola
bis von gesagt immerhin die halbierung
der abhängigkeit von russland ist ein
ganz wichtiger schritt gewesen um jetzt
die von sanktionen zu machen beim öl
sind wir dabei beim gas machen wir auch
fortschritte deshalb weniger
fortschritte weil wir die abhängigkeit
den letzten 20 jahren so massiv erhöht
haben das war ein fehler das ist jetzt
verschüttete milch hilft auch nichts
darüber zu diskutieren das ist leider so
ich sag's mal plastisch freuen wer würde
es darum gehen dass sich jeder ein pulli
anzieht und wie die heizung stadt mit 21
grad mit 17 grad in den wohnzimmern in
deutschland betreiben würde und wir die
hoffnung hätten das würde diesen terror
in der ukraine beenden würde jeder
sofort ja sagen ausdrücklich auch ich
das problem ist und was hat herr wolf
von beschrieben ist würde das heißt
immer so so so niedlich fast
lieferketten abreißen lassen was heißt
das denn ganz konkret das heißt
beispielsweise dass die
grundstoffindustrie in deutschland
faktisch zusammenbricht das heißt zum
beispiel dass wir keine dialyse
schläuche mehr für unsere krankenhäuser
herstellen könnten und jetzt komme ich
zu einem punkt der wichtig ist in diesem
konflikt wo auch wir durchhalten müssen
auch die sanktionen die geopolitische
stärke des westens auch deutschlands ist
die wirtschaftliche stärke das heißt
nicht dass wirtschaft vor humanitäre
hilfe vor auch insbesondere
waffenlieferung oder sowas geht
überhaupt gar nicht aber wenn wir
wirtschaftlich abbrechen sozusagen dann
können wir anderes nicht durchhalten und
dann wäre leider nichts gewonnen in der
summe aber klar ist diese schritte
müssen wir machen die tun wir jetzt auch
und übrigens bei allen sie
beispielsweise bekommen wir ja bereits
was sind da gerade dabei wir reden in
deutschland darüber dass wir wieder
erdgas förderung in der nordsee anfang
märz lächelt also das sind ja dinge die
nicht schon hätte früher näher treten
könne wo viele deutsche parteien gesagt
haben gottes willen also da machen wir
diese zwischenschritte was aber nichts
hilft ist wenn wir uns mehr schaden als
wir ansatzweise putin schaden dann ist
leider den menschen nicht gut sind ein
interessantes und oft gehörtes argument
hobbys schenkel wenn sie in diese
diskussion hören man sollte sich selbst
nicht mehr schaden als dem aggressor ist
das etwas wert in ihren augen und ohren
ja ich habe bei anmerkungen zum diskurs
die ukraine heute
sind keine helden das sind einfach
menschen die leben wollen und die sie
schützen wollen und die auch
verantwortung übernehmen für irland und
für das was im land passiert und das ist
wahrscheinlich auch die stärke an diesem
kampf dass jeder und jede diese
verantwortung übernehmen in ihrem
bereich wo sie was tun können und
aber sie sagen wir waren naiv
ich glaube ich meine diese politische
klasse die jetzt an der macht ist oder
auch früher in letzten 20 jahren es war
keine naivität es war wahrscheinlich
pragmatismus
und auch eine intention wegzuschauen
wenn es um auch um innere politik
russlands ging ja denn ganz viele sachen
wie zum beispiel bei werbung von
homosexuellen menschen folter in
gefängnissen das war ja alles bekannt
überall in der welt putin hat auch
scherze über homosexualität gemacht
irgendwo wo er in europa in westeuropa
also und da wo der weg geschaut das
waren interne sachen und so intern wurde
auch die ukraine politik wahrgenommen
und wenn ich jetzt
auch daran denke wie nach der creme
annexion und nachdem don bass krieg nach
diesen fällen die wir auch erlebt haben
dann nord stream
unterschrieben wurde dann ja war das
glaube ich keine naivität es war was
anderes und was ich sage nur eins war es
und was ich sagen möchte ich glaube es
ist auch die zeit vor allem für deutsche
gesellschaft die schon so viel
durchgemacht hat in dieser bewältigung
des erbes im zweiten weltkrieges auch
verantwortung zu übernehmen ja es ist
schlecht also ich muss ihnen jetzt auch
nicht erzählen wie vor wirtschaftlich
die ukraine steht und wie viele
milliarden sie jeden tag verliert und
aber er will sind wir sind heute alle in
einer ganz schlimmen sind deutsche und
auch die russen also es gibt heute kein
einziges land
welches an diesem krieg an diese sie
deutsche und irgendetwas gewinnt und da
muss sich jede gesellschaft gedanken
machen in welcher welt möchte ich leben
und wofür gar nicht verantwortung
übernehmen und den ukrainer muss jetzt
nicht alles delegiert werden und ich
glaube das wird helfen also ist
natürlich schön aber hier glaube ich ist
es wichtig zu denken wie können wir mit
kämpfen natürlich ist das eine andere
form also nicht rein treten als armee
okay also das ist völlig verständlich
ich glaube es erwartet in die ukraine
auch nicht aber man muss einfach diesen
krieg als nicht humanitäre katastrophe
irgendwo wahrnehmen und wir helfen jetzt
mit unserer wirtschaftlichen stärke
schaffen wir das und so weiter sondern
wir kämpfen zusammen für eine
auf die zeit an also wenn ihr an
seelands richtig versteht und herrn
manager richtig versteht kommt es
wahnsinnig auf die zeit irgendwie und da
ist natürlich die frage ist es ein
argument zu sagen es schadet der
deutschen wirtschaft wenn wir jetzt so
radikal und einschneidend reagieren
frage noch einmal nach stuttgart zu
hören wollt wenn wladimir putin das
jetzt von sich aus entscheiden würde
wenn er einfach festlegt ihr seid
kriegspartei oder aus welchen gründen
auch immer drehe ich jetzt den hahn ab
dann müssten wir damit ja auch klar
kommen
ja das ist natürlich die große gefahr
aus unserer sicht und wir müssen uns
darauf vorbereiten da läuft natürlich
schon einiges es ist ja die
notfallsituation ausgerufen es gibt zwei
weitere stufen und für uns ist es
natürlich wichtig dass wenn der fall
eintritt den wir ja nicht beeinflussen
können das kann ja von sich aus machen
dass wir dann gerüstet sind und ich
glaube das ist ganz wichtig dass jetzt
in den entsprechenden stellen die ja
dann die gaslieferung zu teilen hier
auch änderungen vorgenommen werden
bezüglich der jetzt bestehenden
gesetzlichen regelungen denn wir müssen
unsere wirtschaft am laufen halten die
menschen müssen ihre arbeitsplätze
behalten weil wenn sie die nicht mehr
haben dann können sie als kunde erster
klasse was sie ja sind nach der heutigen
regelung können sie nächstes jahr ihre
gasrechnung nicht mehr bezahlen das
heißt wir müssen eine vernünftige
aufteilung finden das müssen jetzt
notfallpläne gemacht werden wie auch die
industrie am laufen gehalten wird und
was sie sagen es muss im grunde auch
eine neue priorisierung stattfinden
nicht abend zweiter stelle kommen
genauer um der bevölkerung ganz genau da
kann ich dem herrn dürr nur zustimmen
denn wenn sie die leute fragen und ich
habe ja viele menschen in meinem
fabriken und ich spreche mit denen wenn
sie die leute fragen und sagen wollte
lieber bei 17 grad zu hause sitzen und
drei pullover an habe man einen
arbeitsplatz behalten dann sagen ich
sofort ja weil der arbeitsplatz ist ein
ganz wichtiges gut für die menschen und
ist einfach auch wichtig dass wir unser
land am laufen halten und wir müssen
jetzt wege finden und pläne machen wie
wir eben auch die wirtschaft die im
moment ja leider kunde zweiter klasse
ist wie wird die wirtschaft dann auch
versorgen dass sie zumindest notdürftig
am laufen halten fragen die die politik
noch mal herr merz braucht die
wirtschaft eine andere vorrangregelung
in diesen katastrophenschutz plänen die
wir haben soll die der zweite pullover
wichtiger werden oder soll die
wirtschaft wichtiger werden die
auswirkungen eines gaslieferstopps sind
gleichermaßen schwer unabhängig davon
von wem dieser stopp ausgelöst wird und
deswegen war ich uns ein bisschen vor
der illusion zu glauben wenn er es macht
das besser als wenn wir es machen es
wird gleichermaßen
katastrophal wir haben aus dem jahr
1973 ein energie sicherheitsgesetz das
ist mal gemacht worden als wir die
ersten ölpreiskrise hatten da waren wir
mal in einer vergleichbaren lage weit
entfernt von dieser dramatik aber auch
von knappheiten geprägt und da hat der
staat instrumente geschaffen um zu
regulieren das muss diesmal auch
wahrscheinlich wieder geschehen aber ja
herr wolf hat nicht ganz unrecht
natürlich über den sommer kann man mal
mit etwas weniger heizung auskommen zu
hause aber die eigentlich dramatische
zeit wird der nächste winter wenn die
speicher leer sind und wenn der bedarf
wieder ansteigt also es gibt einen
klugen journalisten kollegen der war
letzte woche bei uns in der sendung
robin alexander sagt es macht schon
einen unterschied auch politisch einen
unterschied ob die deutsche
bundesregierung festlegt wir legen wir
machen ein gas embargo oder ob das putin
für uns fest legt auch weil die
bundesregierung natürlich damit rechnen
müssten dass ein entsprechender protest
und ärger
wir sprechen jetzt über die ökonomischen
auswirkungen die politischen
auswirkungen werden sehr unterschiedlich
sein und es ist das ist ein grund warum
ich auch dafür plädiere ist nicht selbst
auszulösen weil wir dann in deutschland
über ein ich hab mit klitschko am
letzten wochenende fast eine stunde
telefoniert und wir haben die argumente
ausgetauscht ich glaube er hat auch
verstanden in welchem dilemma wir hier
sind ich plädiere dafür dass wir das
nicht selber machen denn wir hätten
zusätzlich ein massives problem des
protests in deutschland auch der
spaltung dieser gesellschaft wenn das
umgekehrt kommt wird es uns
möglicherweise eher ein wenig
zusammenschweißen aber das ist eine rein
politische betrachtung die ökonomischen
wirkungen werden gleichermaßen
katastrophe und das sieht die fdp anders
ich fragte jetzt bewusst die ampel und
ich frage bewusst eben die regierung
würden sie der wirtschaft da folgen herr
dürfen sagen die der schaden für dieses
land und seine volkswirtschaftliche
kraft wäre so immens dass wir eine
andere vorrangregelung festlegen müssen
ja ich habe ja gerade selbst eingeführt
frau erinnert dass die geopolitischen
stärke die wir haben gegenüber russland
ist unsere wirtschaftliche stärke weil
wir eben nicht militärisch ein ja wann
könnte der konsequenz genau deswegen
deswegen komme ich darauf zurück ich
würde allerdings nicht sagen ist die
wirtschaftlich hat deswegen
beispielsweise gerade von der
grundstoffindustrie gesprochen weil es
da dramatische folgen hat bei einem
anderen betrieb wäre es vielleicht wo es
nur um wärme versorgen wie wohnzimmer
geht wer ist eine andere situation also
da bin ich offen für eine re
priorisierung der ganzen sache denn es
hat ja recht wir müssen uns auf die
situation auch jetzt schon einstellen
gerade wenn von russischer seite
abgeschaltet wird das ist so insofern
ist das eine aufgabe die wir zu
bewältigen haben zu schauen wo könnte
ein abschalten von russischer seite der
erdgaslieferung und so dramatische
folgen wirtschaftlich bescheren dass
einerseits die arbeitsplätze die herr
wolf an sprach aber unsere lieferketten
so zusammenbrechen dass die eigene
versorgung ich hab das beispiel dialyse
schläuche bewusst genannt greifen da
geht die ganze farbe haben die ganze
nation deutschland und menschen die in
krankenhäusern versorgt werden müssen
also das darf nicht abreißen da ist ich
sag mal plastisch jetzt das wohnzimmer
nicht ganz so prioritär wie
beispielsweise diese situation in der
wirtschaft und der würde dann auch
tatsächlich nicht nur den finanzminister
natürlich nicht das kurzarbeitergeld
reichen
müsste nach anderen stützen sind die
ökonomischen jetzt mal beitrag ich bin
ja auch ökonom habe viele jahre
haushaltspolitik gemacht da da da graut
es mir natürlich auch davor was das
ganze bedeutet keine frage aber mir
geht's so das ist der zweite schritt
schlimm genug der erst über die nicht
hier ist die frage ist hätten wir einen
wirklichen teil zusammenbruch sozusagen
in der wirtschaft und der muss natürlich
vermieden werden weil dann wären wir
geopolitisch auf einmal in einer extrem
geschwächten sieht heißt auch ich
versuche es zusammenzufassen es geht
eigentlich nicht nur um geld sondern es
geht auch um mangelt es geht auch um
einen einen faktischen
physischen verlust rettung einen
massiven wohlstandsverlust wollen wir
stehen gehören ärmer sie haben einige
situationen einheit stehen wir vor einem
massiven wohlstand fall ist in diesem
oder museums werden betriebe kaputt
gehen die wir so schnell nicht wieder
aufgebaut bekommt nun meldet sich auch
winfried kretschmann zu wort herr masala
das ist interessant und sagt die gas und
gas importstopp verhindert keine
kriegsverbrechen ich kann jetzt nicht
erkennen was das begehen solcher
verbrechen wie in butter darauf hob er
ab mit gaslieferungen zu tun hat sein
argument soll sein dass man die
brutalität den krieg selbst mit einem
embargo und natürlich nicht sofort
beendet ist das ein argument er
natürlich ist das ein argument aber es
ist ein komplett naives und domes
argument verzeihen sie mir das ist das
so sage weil natürlich verhindern wir
mit sanktionen in diesen krieg nicht
putin hat diesen krieg geplant putin
will in politisch durchführen und so
lange er das kann wird er das machen und
sanktionen wirken halt nicht also
sanktionen wirken nicht wenn ich hier
heute verhänge morgen so von daher keine
der sanktionen die frau die die in der
letzten zeit verhängt wurden also auch
das fünfte sanktionspaket der
europäischen union das jetzt kommen wird
wird diesen krieg stoppen übermorgen
sondern sanktionen werden möglicherweise
den russischen staat so in die knie
zwingen das in 567 dann müsste man die
ökonomen seien um das richtig
auszurechnen dieser staat einfach so
pleite ist dass er dann nicht mehr das
geld hat um seinen staatsapparat und
noch mal wissen der staatsapparat führt
diesen krieg das militär macht das vor
ort der staatsapparat ist unterstützend
tätig das sozusagen der staatsapparat
nicht mehr finanziert werden kann dass
ihn vielleicht das geld ausgeht um
sozusagen soldaten zu bezahlen und so
weiter und so fort als zu sagen
natürlich verhindert ein gasstopp keine
kriegsverbrechen unmittelbar oder
mittelbar natürlich weil wie man könnte
ja auch folgendes argumentieren und
deswegen ist diese diskussion ja
unsinnig also wir verhängen jetzt
sozusagen alle möglichen sanktionen in
fünf monaten ist dieser staat pleite und
russland so zu sagen hier ist die weiße
flagge und sagt gehören auf da
verhindern wir auch nicht dass beim
rausgehen der russischen truppen noch
alles getötet wird was ich denen in den
weg stellten ja also das argument ist
kein valides was er gerade mal da
vorbringt und dann noch mal die frage
was sollten diese sanktionen in bezug
auf putin bewirken noch mal die frage
ist es nicht wahnsinnig schwer
abzuschätzen wann wir diesen machthaber
so sehr reizen dass er aus diesem in die
ecke gedrängt seien noch viel schlimmere
dinge tut als wir befürchten absolut
richtig das risiko besteht immer und
dieses risiko muss man eingehen in
diesem fall aber sie haben einen sehr
wichtigen punkt angesprochen der mir
selber unklar ist
was sollen diese sanktionen bewirken und
das ist nie offen ausgesprochen worden
also wir haben am 24 februar oder am 25
das massivste sanktionspaket gegen einen
staat verhangen seit dem ende des
zweiten weltkrieges aber was ist das
strategische ziel krieg stoppen kann es
nicht sein wollen wir sozusagen den
krieg den den start in die in die knie
zwingen damit er den krieg stoppt wollen
wir sozusagen die bevölkerung gegen das
regime aufwiegeln wollen wir in dem
regime sozusagen widerstand locken von
bestimmten gruppen die getroffen werden
also man muss mit diesen sanktionen auch
ein strategisches ziel formulieren und
das meines erachtens haben wir nicht
getan deswegen machen wir immer
sanktionen sanktionen sanktionen aber es
ist nicht so ganz klar was wir
eigentlich erzielen wo frau ist schenkel
hat das russische volk schon
angesprochen sie haben auch verwandte
und freunde natürlich in der eden
russland und wir wissen hier und nehmen
nicht nur zur kenntnis sondern wie
erfolgreich die mir putin natürlich auch
propaganda macht in seine bevölkerung
hinein die nicht nur zu 80 prozent
diesen krieg den er so nicht nennen gut
heißt sondern ihn sogar noch befeuert
jetzt erfolgreich zu sein darin also da
treffen sich ja zwei fragen ist es denn
realistisch darauf zu hoffen dass sich
irgendwann die russische bevölkerung
auch gegen diesen präsidenten wendet ich
glaube dass es nicht bald passiert dass
die struktur der gesellschaft oder ich
weiß nicht wirklich dass gesellschaft
nennen kann denn putin hat alles
mögliche gemacht wurden immer ja keinen
gesellschaftlichen estland
funktioniert ja der protest kommt nicht
von unten aber ich glaube was sie bei
dieser abschnitte über diese abschätzung
gesprochen haben wir in der ukraine
können ja auch nicht abschätzen wir
machen einfach und das ist glaube ich so
in einem krieg oder in einem konflikt
man muss einfach alles machen damit das
gestoppt wird und ohne genau zu wissen
wissen sie das erinnert ein bisschen an
diese alte diskussion was ist denn
putins kopf
als ich schon das letzte mal das ist ja
das ist nicht wichtig was in seinem kopf
ist wichtig ist was er tut und wie man
ihn stoppt und das ist die aufgabe gut
dann nehmen wir uns jetzt aber genau das
noch mal vorher märz und fragen
wenigstens genauso wichtig nicht nur
wohin sollen diese sanktionen zielen
sondern was ist in diesem krieg
eigentlich das ziel des westens wollen
wir bleibt die mir putin zurückdrängen
aus diesen territorien wollen wir dass
er sogar gezwungen wird beim
wiederaufbau zu helfen dieses landes
dass er jetzt pulverisiert oder wollen
wir eine geteilte ukraine und wollen ihm
zugestehen dass er bestimmte regionen
haben darf um dann einen frieden mit
ihnen zu schließen das war alles das ist
alles ein bisschen zu kurz ich finde wir
wir helfen sich das haben sie eben ganz
wichtig gesagt sondern wir verteidigen
auch unsere freiheit und auf angela von
einheit sehen in kiew verteidigt er in
mario pohl und das ziel der masala ich
finde ein wichtiges ziel muss sein und
das wird auch artikuliert dem
industriellen militärischen komplex
dieses landes das rückgrat zu brechen
ich spreche einfach aus und dafür zu
sorgen dass diese kriegsmaschinerie
zusammenbricht
ökonomisch zusammenbricht und nicht mehr
in der lage ist nachschub zu bekommen
deswegen ja auch die der stopp
sämtlicher elektronikteile alles was aus
dem westen kommt um diese
kriegsmaschinerie am laufen so gut aber
dann muss man auch sagen herr merz wenn
das so wichtig ist dann müssen jedoch
ein embargo machen wir müssen doch dann
alles tun was wir tun auch sehr sehr
viel also ich noch mal wir sind wieder
bei dem was er eben diskutiert haben wir
tun alles das was wir meinen
verantworten zu können auch gegenüber
unserem eigenen land um so viel wie
möglich ist hat noch nie in der
geschichte der modernen zeit ein solches
sanktionsregime gegeben gegen personen
gegen unternehmen gegen länder die
beteiligt sind insbesondere russland
sind ja auch noch andere beteiligt also
insofern glaube ich sind wir da schon
auf einem weg etwas zu tun dass ich am
ende als richtig erweisen könnte wissend
dass wir damit trotzdem unendliches
menschliches leid nicht verhindert haben
wenn wir denn wenigstens mit unseren
waffenlieferungen erfolgreicher wären
womit wir bei einem thema sind das hier
auch schon kurz angedeutet wurde und das
auch kein gutes kapitel ist weil herr
dürr die
verteidigungsministerin regelmäßig sich
selbst lobt und sagt was wir alles schon
tolles in die ukraine gebracht haben und
dann immer die ukrainische seite
entweder herr seeh lenski oder herr
melnik sagen dass das leider alles nicht
stimmt und sogar dass sie lügt können
sie irgendwas zum schutze der
verteidigungsministerin anführen also
deutschland tut auch militärisch was ich
habe das eine beispiel voran genannt
nämlich bewaffnete panzer und auch da
die zeitenwende vor zwei jahren hätte
sich niemand vorstellen können in
deutschland dass wir in eine
konfliktsituation waffen liefern das tun
wir jetzt richtigerweise denn das ist ja
die ganz konkrete hilfe für die soldaten
soldaten die da die freiheit verteidigen
wir liefern keine mader ja ich bin ich
bin offen dafür also ich bin da durchaus
offen für darüber zu sprechen wie wir
mehr tun können die nato hat ja heute
dazu getagt und haben auch hinweise
gegeben da müssen wir uns jetzt auch in
deutschland anschauen was wir umsetzen
können dass eine beispiel habe ich
genannt nämlich diese bewaffneten panzer
bewaffnete panzer immerhin und ich bin
auch bereit darüber zu reden dass das
was beispielsweise auf den höfen der
deutschen rüstungskonzerne derzeit steht
und nicht genutzt wird ob man das
freigeben kann natürlich müssen wir
genau darüber nachdenken das jetzt zu
tun denn wir müssen es als das wird der
massa wahrscheinlich besser beurteilen
können als ich aber auch so zu ende
denken das heißt wenn man waffen liefert
muss man auch munition liefern
gegebenenfalls auch ausbildungssituation
und gern hier in eine situation kommen
dass dieser furchtbare furchtbare krieg
länger dauert was wir alle nicht hoffen
aber was sein kann doch da müssen wir
jetzt militärisch darüber nachdenken wie
wir genau auch länger die soldaten
soldaten der ukraine unterstützen
unterstützen und dann sind hier hermanns
hat aber genau bei der gleichen frage
eigentlich sehen sie noch durch wann die
bundesregierung ja sagt und wann sie
nein sagt also nva panzer aus dem
bestand über tschechien haben wir jetzt
offensichtlich geliefert bei den männern
sagen wir nein und warum sagen an einer
stelle wenn ich das tschuldigung ganz
kurz sagen darf muss ich dann aber schon
auch die verteidigungsministerin
verteidigung den inseln aus einem als
einen ganz pragmatischen grund was nicht
ganz funktioniert leider in so einer
sicherheitspolitisch schwierigen
situation dass wir sozusagen transparent
offen legen auf welchem weg was gerade
genau passiert weil das wird schwierig
das ist nicht muss man fairerweise sagen
ja natürlich wünscht sich jeder diese
transparenz und würde gerne sehen dass
an munition das an was die wird konkret
die frage also wenn er soll das da bin
dann bin ich absolut dabei ich finde so
zu sagen wer das nicht nicht nur wir
deutschen alle reden zu viel über
waffenlieferungen so man sollte es
machen ende ausmachen und nicht so viel
darüber reden also darauf da kann ich
nur sagen ist das argument ja in der
auseinandersetzung mit dem
bundesverteidigungsministerium zu sagen
es geht ja gar nicht darum dass sie
einen bestimmten ort angeben oder dass
sie bestimmte kontakte angeben oder
fotos zeigen wo das hingeht sondern es
geht um die dimension und unsere
dimension herr masala da sind wir jetzt
ist ein zehntel von estland nein nein
also wie das kommt darauf an wie man es
berechnet na also sagen wir man wenn man
es ist es die frage nennen obertal wert
ist also entweder sind wir fast so gut
wie island ja was natürlich auch mama
musste die karte gruppen
bruttoinlandsprodukt von erster und
bevölkerung oder wir liegen darunter
aber das ist die frage wie man es
berechnet ich gehe jetzt mal positiv
davon aus und dem die zahlen des
wirtschaftsministeriums jene anderer
berechnungsgrundlage haben als das
verteidigungsministerium dann sind wir
ungefähr da wo island ist und mit mit
sachen die jetzt schon bewilligt sind
werden wir demnächst kurz vor estland
sein und vergleichbar und da sind wir im
bereich von irgendwo 250 millionen euro
280 millionen euro
die usa geben 1,6 milliarden bisher wird
um nur mal den spitzenreiter zu nennen
ja und die nummer 23 45 kann ich gar
nicht
deswegen ist das sind unterschiedliche
sozusagen berechnungsart im
quartalsbericht das
wirtschaftsministerium befinden sie 200
180 millionen so 180 minuten 203
millionen dollar das ist aber sozusagen
weil die frau lamprecht sozusagen den
den nennwert nimmt also wieviel könnt
ihr heute wert und und das
wirtschaftsministerium nimmt sozusagen
den absoluten wert wie viel ist das
gerät an sich werden können wir mehr
oder könnten wir eigentlich nicht mehr
sind diese argumente alle richtig zu
sagen wir können nur liefern was den
ukrainern auch wirklich nutzt wir können
nur liefern was die ukraine auch
wirklich haben wollen auch wenn die
ukraine die ganze zeit sagen ihr wisst
seit zwei monaten was wir brauchen und
es nicht bekommen also ich kenne die
liste nicht aber ich sage jetzt mal
folgendes natürlich können wir mehr
machen weil wir sozusagen einkaufen
können also es geht nicht nur um das was
die bundeswehr hat sondern es geht auch
darum dass wir irgendwo einkaufen können
es geht auch darum dass wir der ukraine
erlauben bei deutschen
rüstungsunternehmen einzukaufen wenn ich
jetzt dieses bestimmte mader beispiel
nehme ja da verhindern wir gerade ich
weiß nicht ob sich das jetzt gerade ich
glaube heute tagte das bundes
sicherheitskabinett so fleisch ist eine
veränderung der position aber das
verhindern wir gerade dass die ukraine
direkt zu einem metallzaun durchgehen
können und sagen können hier geld da
mata wir wollen haben
gleichzeitig verhindern wir auch dass
wir folgendes machen wir haben ungefähr
390 marder in der bundeswehr 300 sind
gebunden 90 sind sogenannte umlauf
reserven die könnten wir geben das ist
angenehm und rein und dann haben wir
irgendwo ein ordentlich steuern mit
hofmann mit den mardern und jetzt sagt
rheinmetall pass auf wir setzen die in
stand vier bis sechs monate von den 90
können wir alle 90 oder einige in der
ukraine geben und dann kommen in vier
monaten diese mal wieder zurück das
heißt wir verlieren keine mader der
bestand bleibt gleich aber es verzögert
sich sozusagen vier monate und es ist
jetzt mal so was sage in den nächsten
vier monaten die russische föderation
ist gerade anderweitig gebunden wir
werden nicht die baltischen staaten
überfallen so dass sozusagen wir den
verteidigungsfall haben und wenn die
verteidigung der baltischen staaten und
40 mann hängt dann sollten wir es liegen
sie gar nicht beginnen also von daher
sozusagen das ist kein argument wir
könnten mehr machen und jetzt kommt
entscheidende punkt wenn ich die minute
noch habe dieser krieg wird jetzt über
monate gehen dort hat eben angedeutet
was man jetzt machen kann und gehen
irgendwann mal nicht nur uns deutschen
sondern auch den polen den bulgaren die
alten sowjetischen modelle aus die man
den ukrainern liefern kann wo sie sofort
soldaten einsetzen und das ding fahren
können jetzt können wir überlegen ob wir
ihnen westliche systeme liefern ob wir
die zeit haben sie verkürzt zu
trainieren und gleichzeitig war es ganz
wichtig ist die logistikkette her
natürlich es hilft nichts wenn wir was
westliche ist in die ukraine schicken
das geht dann irgendwie kaputt nicht mal
die russin ist kaputt schießen sondern
weil irgendwas kaputt geht und die haben
keine ersatzteile also da brauchen wir
eine logistikkette wenn dieser krieg
noch monate dauert wenn das die annahme
ist haben wir jetzt zeit über ganz ganz
andere arten von waffenlieferungen
nachzudenken und unterstützung
nachzudenken und heute ist in der nato
herr stoltenberg fällt mir gerade einen
noch einmal von ihm auch selbst erwähnt
worden dass finnland und frieden und
georgien dabei war wird das auch noch
mal was an unserem denken darüber ändern
aus welchen ländern und wie massiv wir
eben alles was sich jetzt ja haufen nato
gebiet befindet und oder noch nicht nato
mitglied ist
einbezogen wird in den kampf
ich hoffe es also es wäre schön wenn
diese zeitenwende dadurch gekennzeichnet
wird dass die bundesrepublik deutschland
jetzt endlich mal vor die bugwelle kommt
bisher haben wir noch immer einen alten
reflex den wir aus den letzten 30 jahren
kennen wir gucken was die wichtigsten
partner machen und in dem moment wo wir
befürchten dass wir alleine da stehen
also laufen bei schnellen kevin allein
zu hause sagen okay wir machen ja man
muss auch einfach mal gehen diese
zeitenwende wurde eingeleitet weil unser
engster partner bei wir liefern keine
waffen die niederlande gesagt haben wir
liefern waffen und da standen wir
plötzlich allein da dann haben wir den
180 grad schwenk vollzogen letzten endes
agieren wir noch immer so wir warten was
die anderen sagen und wenn wir sehen wir
sind isoliert dann gehen wir sind noch
mal bei der
bundesverteidigungsministerium herr merz
olaf scholz hat gesagt er macht diese
100 milliarden vermögen für die
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr zur
chefsache
hat er misstrauen in die bundeswehr oder
hat er misstrauen in seine verteidigungs
ministerin ist das nicht alles auch eine
chance entscheidung die wir in bezug auf
unsere waffen liefern ja wir hatten wir
hatten gestern im deutschen bundestag
eine regierungsbeteiligung wir haben den
bundeskanzler danach gefragt wenn die
antworten gegeben hätte die er massa
laut der abend gegeben hat dann wäre die
sache klar gewesen aber er hat fragen
beantwortet die wir ihm nicht gestellt
haben und die gestellten fragen hat er
nicht beantwortet wir werden hier
bewusst im nebel gehalten im ungewissen
gehalten was tatsächlich passiert und
wissen sie dann kommen solche
absonderlichen dinge zustande wie die
verteidigungsministerien behauptet wir
seien der zweitgrößte lieferant und dann
wird man nach gefragt woran das den
bemessen wird wie das den bemessen da
kommt die antwort aus dem
verteidigungsministerium zu halten sie
sich fest dass es ernst nach gewicht ja
was das war die antwort aus dem
verteidigungsministerium es fängt jetzt
an wirklich ärgerlich zu werden
parlament und öffentlichkeit werden von
dieser bundesregierung getäuscht zum
teil sagt die verteidigungsministerin
die unwahrheit sie sagt ist seien
verabredungen mit der ukraine gemacht
worden über die geheimhaltung das ist
von der ukrainischen regierung zweimal
glasklar dementiert worden wir werden
hier nicht wirklich gut informiert es
werden dinge zurückgehalten die längst
hätten geliefert werden können wir
wissen dass es in der bundesregierung
massive unstimmigkeiten zwischen
kanzleramt verteidigungsministerium
wirtschaftsministerium geht die die
exportgenehmigungen enteilen das ist das
eigentliche problem was man langsam
wirklich anfängt ärgerlich zu werden die
wollen auch mit der auseinandersetzung
die wir darüber im parlament führen
müssen und die wir uns alle gerne
ersparen wiewohl man der fairness halber
sagen muss das oberteil jetzt auch
leichter hat neue waffen zu genehmigen
als die aus dem bestand der bundeswehr
in ihrer an einem motor ist er ist nicht
raus dort kommt es nicht aus das heißt
auch sie sagen eigentlich ist olaf
scholz dafür zu stellen das ist
chefsache und wenn seine
kabinettsmitglieder ist nicht so machen
wie er es will der muss aus anordnen er
hat die richtlinienkompetenz und muss es
zur seiner eigenen sache machen das ist
doch genau der eindruck der immer wieder
entsteht dass deutschland ständig
hinterher läuft und deutschland ständig
aufgefordert werden muss und deutschland
sich nicht mit denen zusammen bewegt die
jetzt hier entscheidungen und dann wird
die aussenministerin heute aus dem
nato-rat zurückgerufen weil sie hier in
deutschland im bundestag um die mehrheit
fürchten beim ins gesetz das ist einfach
nicht in ordnung stellt sich den
eindruck vor der da in brüssel entsteht
aber bleiben wir bei der
verteidigungsministerin und fragen noch
mal ist sie eine gute nein sie ist
völlig überfordert sie ist völlig
ungeeignet gewesen vom ersten tag an wo
sie ins amt kam es ist eine reine
notlösung und man merkt es jeden tag
also jetzt müssen sie schon übermorgen
gar nicht mehr zurück die rolle des
oppositionspolitikers ist es auch mal
auf den tisch zu hauen absolut legitim
aber viele dinge stimmen nicht sie hier
schon widerspruch zwischen ihnen beiden
sie sagen zurecht wir können nicht über
jedes einzelne waffensystem und dann
noch den weg dahin reden sondern wir
müssen es machen ich bin absolut dabei
verstand wieder gut dabei auch mehr zu
tun über das waffensystem über das ich
vorhin sprach was die bundesregierung
jetzt genehmigt hat was geliefert wird
aus diesen beständen dann standort
tschechien derzeit und das kommt auch
das ist da gab es eine anfrage schon mal
und zwar 2009/10 und da hat die alte
bundesregierung nein zugesagt das meine
ich war riesig und ab da gab es die
besetzung der krim märz ist es ja nicht
also das ist das was die ich habe vor
mit naivität beschrieben oder wir haben
weggeschaut sie haben das recht gesagt
das haben wir in der vergangenheit getan
die ausrede lautet nicht diese
bundesregierung ist erst 120 tage im amt
aber mit verlaub wenn man vorher herr
merz war persönlich nicht dabei sondern
eine andere vorgängerin war im
kanzleramt wenn man 16 jahre eine
komplett nicht nur andere energiepolitik
darüber sprachen wir sondern auch eine
komplett andere militär politik gemacht
hat dann sollte man vielleicht nicht
ganz so laut auf die ihr jahre auf den
namen herbert das ist auch richtig das
waren die besten jahre der der
unionsgeführten bundesregierung damals
dass ich mich den den dem punkt noch
sagen ich bin sehr offen dafür dass das
was herr stoltenberg heute angekündigt
hat dass wir das auch in deutschland
vollziehen die amas alter ist sagte ist
dann auch machen und am besten im
westlichen konzert und so dass es auch
funktioniert die amerikaner haben ein
vorteil diese logistischen lieferketten
über die wir sprachen die notwendig sind
das nicht nur symbolisch gerät geliefert
wird sondern auch angewendet werden kann
gegen die russischen aggression das
haben die amerikaner bereits weil die
alte bundesregierung mit verlaub da
nichts getan hat das müssen wir jetzt
auch aufbauen also ja ich bin dafür dass
wir da militärisch unterstützen